我今年37岁，
甘律师十几年了，
想跟你们聊一聊关于两性关系里面的一些规律，
希望屏幕前年轻可爱的你早点知道，
少走弯路，
少吃亏。
第一，
霍尊和陈露的爱情，
早在这个女孩放弃自己舞蹈事业那天起，
就已经注定了结局。
无论这个男朋友是霍尊，
还是刘尊、
马尊、
李尊、
张尊，
这个女孩儿都注定被抛弃。
我这么说，
你们可能会觉得我太武断太绝对，
又是毒鸡汤，
没有关系，
认真听这背后的规律。
这个世界上唯一不变的就是变化本身，
爱情也不例外，
对不对？
无论你跟谁谈恋爱，
感情本身就是在不断发生着变化的。
当初对你的海誓山盟，
万般疼爱不是假的，
是真的，
今天对你的冷嘲热讽、
爱搭不理，
甚至拳打脚踢，
弃之如敝履也是真的。
如果你寄希望于男人信手当初爱你时的承诺，
画出对你好一辈子的。
的大饼，
那这本身就是痴心妄想，
是违反规律的。
就拿晨露来举例子，
一个舞蹈演员，
你最有魅力的时刻就是在聚光灯下享受万众瞩目，
观众鼓掌、
欢呼、
惊叹的那一刻。
当一个男人从万千观众眼里看到他们对你的仰慕那一瞬间，
他会不自觉的生发出一种独占鳌头的喜悦和成就感。
而你想要得到这个男人长久的倾慕，
就必须让自己一直在那个闪闪发光的舞台上扮演一个仙子。
一旦失去舞台，
失去灯光，
失去观众对你的垂涎欲滴，
你就变得泯然众人。
那么这个男人在看你的时候，
你跟隔壁天天唠叨张家长、
李家短、
鸡毛蒜皮的张大姐、
刘大妈别无差异。
同样的案例，
李若彤也用她的亲身经历为我们演绎过了，
当她是万千男人心目中白月光小龙女的时候，
在男朋友面前，
她却是如。
如同仙子般美轮美奂的存在，
当他放弃自己的事业，
全身心投入到爱情家庭中之后，
身上的光渐渐熄灭了，
最终感情上的结局跟程度是没有区别的，
只不过小龙女终归是小龙女，
分手也保持着应有的体面而已。
有些人可能会告我，
难道就没有至死不渝的爱情了吗？
有大多都是一方死在了最相爱的时候，
比如甄嬛传中的纯缘，
比如泰坦尼克号中的杰克，
如果纯元活得长，
结局可能还比不上如意，
如果杰克不死，
女主角跟着他私奔上岸之后过不了半年，
这女的就肯定得逃离这种天天吃不饱饭，
没法洗澡洗头，
没钱买牙膏，
上厕所没有纸，
晚上只能睡公园睡天桥的日子。
对不起，
请原谅我毁了你们的美好想象。
第二，
与其把本钱投资在男人身上，
给他买手表、
买衣服、
丽人设、
开公司铺路搭桥。
不如投资在自。
己身上，
该考研考研，
该培训培训，
哪怕你花钱去健身、
去跳舞、
去锻炼身体也是好的。
因为从概率上来讲，
你所投资的男人可能有50%的几率会背叛你。
但这个世界上唯一不会背叛你的就是你自己。
如果你算明白这个账，
就知道手上这些钱该怎么花了。
第三，
这个世界上女人痛苦的根源大多来自于高估了自己在男人心目中的地位和分量。
如果现在你觉得你的男朋友爱你有10分，
那么请你打个7折，
如果你觉得他爱你有8分，
你可以再打个8折。
我为什么这么说？
这是有调查依据的。
如果你找100个会开车的人来做测试，
问他们自认为自己的开车水平是中上等还是中下等，
会有900多个人都认为自己的开车水平是中上等。
如果你找1000个人来做问卷，
问他们，
你自认为你的颜值水平是中上等还是中下等？
会有900多个人觉得自己的相貌中上等。
杨丽说，
他不理解为什么很多男的明明看上去那么普通，
却又那么自信。
其实女人也一样，
高估自己在男人心目中的地位和分量会带来什么后果呢？
最典型的就是无法面对被分手、
被抛弃的结局。
你以为他离不开你，
你以为他离开你根本活不下去，
你以为他在规划和你的未来，
其实人家早就已经权衡利弊，
做好取舍了。
所以姑娘们清醒一点，
你在他心里真的没那么重要。
最后我想说啊，
这个视频不是为了谁辩护的，
我是想用最刺骨扎心的语言来提醒那些善良的姑娘，
你可以善良，
但不能太傻太蠢太天真。